and the weapons the tools mr. clay used
to terrorize the citizens of new
Bordeaux I suppose you furnished him
with those as well actually no ha ha
don't get me wrong senator I would have
given him any gun knife or bomb he asked
for what can I do for you Lincoln clay
but like I've said Lincoln never had
trouble finding a weapon just how does
he accomplish that help me kill Salma
Khan Oh for most of that summer one of
his underboss is Cassandra she ran the
Haitian gang looped him into a sweet
little arm smuggling ring she had going
that kept him squared away yes - is the
current hit you use a full-service
operation name - please pistols rifles
shotguns ammo you name it it was all
black marketeer for I mean this was a
real arsenal if the VC had been this
well provision at the drain the whole
damn war might have turned out different
extended clip perfectly tuned sight
hollow points silencers by the time
Lincoln finished tinkering with a
firearm it was a precision instrument of
death nothing like this would ever
happen before Lincoln wanted to terrify
the mob he wanted them to know he was
going to kill every last one of them
then Jesus then when Burke came on board
things really picked up another level
part explosives everything from Molotov
cocktails to c4 you know this stuff they
use for controlled demolition
except in our case not not always so
control data with a loud crash like a
bomb going off war on the street for the
gunmen stormed the Royal Hotel killing
an untold number of men you know the
funny part is the funny part is Lincoln
didn't really need half the [ __ ] to take
down marcano
and the systematic killing of mark
ahmo's Kappos in lieutenant well we
weren't playing [ __ ] pattycake Christ
fighting to him was like breathing
I've seen him bring a whole DC unit to
his knees using nothing but it's nice
I've seen him take apart an armored
encampment from the canopy with a single
scoped combat right put a rocket
launcher in the hands of a man like that
and those poor bastards never stood a
chance
even back in Laos when rerunning guns
hell almost from the moment he stepped
off the chopper I remember thinking to
myself this man has a talent for
violence
you